[Musique]
le royaume uni veut des transports plus
vert plus vite
londres de vence à 2035 l'interdiction
de la vente de véhicules neufs qui roule
à essence ou diesel
même les véhicules hybrides seront
exclues et tout ça cinq ans plus tôt que
prévu selon le premier ministre boris
johnson c'est la seule façon d'atteindre
l'objectif la neutralité carbone dans
l'ensemble du pays d'ici 2050 pour
l'instant à peine 5 % des nouveaux
véhicules vendus sont électriques que
des experts suggèrent que 2020 pourrait
être un point tournant parce que le
nombre de modèles électriques offerts
votre doublé dans le pays
le nonce critiqué par les
environnementalistes qui demande de plan
concret pour la transition
le secteur aérien aussi s'engage à être
carboneutre d'ici 30 ans et ce malgré la
croissance prévue de 70% du trafic de
passagers
[Musique]